you've made it to the last lab in the
quest after you can wait this lab on
quick labs you'll finally unlock your
badge on this episode we're gonna go
over what you'll learn in this final lab
Google genomics Quick Start Google
genomics helps the life science
community organize the world's genomic
information and make it accessible and
useful
big genomic data is here today with
petabytes rapidly growing towards
exabytes Google genomics is an API that
is part of the Google cloud platform
through this and other add-ons you can
apply the same technologies that power
Google search and maps to securely store
process explore and share large complex
datasets in this lab you'll use Google's
implementation of the HTS git protocol
and Sam tools to create a project and
view some public data for yourself to
access to know mcdhh Atta stored in
Google Cloud Storage you can use
Google's implementation of the HTS kit
protocol defined by the Global Alliance
for genomics and health Google's HTS kit
implementation makes it easy to access
and share data stored in your own cloud
projects without copying large files to
and from compute engine virtual machines
you can also use the HTS kit server to
access data from public sources like
Google's mirror of the thousand genomes
project is this it is this the last lab
on your quest congratulations we want to
hear from you tell us about your
experience following this quick laps
quest and how you're applying what
you've learned in your own applications
in the comments below we'll see you next
months when we embark on our next quest
essentials